when you fall jesus says
get up he does not say stay down there i
want to leave you alone for six months
i'm putting you on probation
he says get up i have paid the price
if you will believe no matter what the
enemy is telling you in your head and in
your heart
you've got to say i know in whom i have
believed
the blood of jesus christ his son
cleanses me from all sin
have you ever wondered about those
voices in your head is it god
is it your conscience or something else
find out on this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness
everyone welcome to led live we are
excited for you to join us today
and we have a guest again on our program
eric wilson who's been a guest in our
show multiple times thank you for
joining
us it's good to be here you know
whenever i go out and speak i always
tell people
you know it's important that if you're
going to get a message that you get it
from the right
source and so that's kind of what this
topic
is about today is getting messages from
the right source what are those sources
where do people in this world get some
of those messages
sometimes it's very strange and we're
going to talk about that today
so you were reminding us just prior to
the show
that there was a quote by the actress
sandra bullock
yes you have that with you i do i've got
it with me um
and sort of as a preface before i show
that quote
a lot of people talk about being
inspired
i mean you hear musicians you hear
writers authors
movie stars they're like man that was an
inspiration that was inspired
yeah but a lot of people don't really
stop to think what does that mean
inspired it means in spirited
inspiration means a spirit
was in you it was put in you in spirited
wow and we're not going to talk a whole
lot on this one about
the dark side we're going to lay the
foundation
with the truth but i want to show you
this
this is a quote from an actress sandra
bullock and she said
when she's acting and she comes under
this inspiration this power she says
it's
almost like my conscience and
my devil all in one and i'm like
yeah i don't want to claim the devil is
mine yeah yeah what do you mean by that
and then she says it's almost like i can
read minds at this point
instinct or intuition or a sick sense
that's like our gift as actors and
actresses
so she's speaking for actors in general
yeah so
i'm assuming because she said that she's
had conversations with other actors and
they agree
yes yes
the easiest way for me to look at this
is you go okay so what's the point
i mean what's the difference about
these voices well jesus said something
in john chapter 6 verse 63
he said the words i speak unto you they
are spirit and their life
and then in john 14 verse 10 and 11 he
said
the words i'm speaking unto you it's not
me speaking them it's my father that's
inside of me he's giving me the words
and he's the one that's doing the work
all the miracles you're seeing it's god
in me
doing those that's what he wants for us
but yet the enemy wants the same thing
he wants to take
god's throne in luke chapter 17 verse 20
and 21
uh there's something very powerful there
that our saviors told us he said
when he was demanded by the pharisees
when the kingdom of god would come
because they were expecting
you know a monarch inflaming you know
robes and a fiery chariot and he was
going to crush the romans and
but they didn't realize that christ's
kingdom
began in humility
the second coming it will be in power
but listen to what he said when he was
demanded by the pharisees when the
kingdom of god should come
jesus answered them and said behold
the kingdom of god is within you
it's inside of you and most of them
didn't have a clue
they didn't get it in john chapter 3
when nicodemus came to jesus that night
you know when no one else was around he
was even asking about that
he wanted to find out about this kingdom
because he saw jesus doing
all the things that the hebrew
scriptures told
that the messiah would do but yet he was
not taking the throne he was not seeking
recognition
and he was trying to understand you know
this this
how this was working one of the things
that that really caught my attention a
couple of years ago
i was reading in the gospels and i was
reading
specifically when jesus right before
jesus had begun his ministry
and it said that john the baptist came
preaching
repentance and saying behold the kingdom
of god
is at hand and when i remember when i
read that because even growing up a
christian
when you talked about the kingdom of god
it was like the second coming
you know that was just a picture that
most christians have in their mind
and i'm reading i'm like this was 2 000
years ago
john the baptist said the kingdom of
heaven is at hand
and i was like and then in my mind i
thought
yeah but john wasn't god he could have
been mistaken peter
thought jesus was coming in his day he
was mistaken
and then i read over another chapter or
two and jesus
was baptized went into the wilderness
and was tempted of the devil and he came
back from the wilderness and he said
behold
the kingdom of god is at hand and i was
like okay john could be mistaken
jesus was not mistaken and i thought
god that was 2000 years ago how could
the kingdom be at hand
and the lord just impressed me said eric
look up the word kingdom
so i looked the word up and i've got the
hebrew definition these are the strong's
concordance numbers if you're looking
you know with our audience
and i've also got the greek definition
the hebrew definition
of kingdom is to have dominion to
rule to reign as a king
to induct into royalty or to ascend the
throne
the greek definition is royalty to rule
to reign a foundation of power
or a sovereign king the kingdom
of god is at hand the king
the foundation you know it talks about
jesus and it says
he's the foundation stone but it also
says
he's the headstone he's the beginning
and the end when you start a pyramid
it's got a cornerstone
and it's got a capstone christ just like
i'm both
i'm alpha and omega his kingdom
began 2 000 years ago and we are living
in the days when we're going to see
him take the crown that's interesting
that like the devil he just counterfeits
the things of god and you know you see
the pyramid on the dollar bill without
the
capstone on it and it's almost like
satan's saying like no no no i'm the
i'm that capstone i'm the guy that sees
everything but
satan doesn't really have that that kind
of power that god does
sees everything so i think it's just
another counterfeit of trying to be in
the place of god
and that eye that you see over the the
pyramid on the dollar bill that's the
eye of horus
it's lucifer saying i'm going to put my
seat where god's throne is supposed to
be
and we're going to get into that i don't
want to go too far ahead
listen this we're going to look at the
old testament first this is in micah
chapter 5. and this is a beautiful
prophecy
the lord spoke through micah and he said
but thou
bethlehem ephrata though thou be little
among the thousands of judah
yet out of thee shall he come forth unto
me
that is to be ruler or king in
israel isn't that just like god though
that he doesn't just say he's going to
come out of the best and the
and the biggest and the whatever it's
like even from the beginning you see his
fingerprint always taking the more
humble of approach to it
do you know what really catches my
attention remember what jesus said
behold the kingdom is within you
do you know it says in first corinthians
chapter three
and chapter six and second corinthians
chapter six it says
what know you not that your body
is the temple of the holy spirit which
is in you
which you are not of which you have of
god and you are not your own
it says our bodies are god's temple
in zechariah chapter 6 verse 13 it says
he will sit upon his throne and be a
priest upon his throne
the temple of god was not just okay
there's church in their state
god's like i'm both i'm your priest
and your king and i have one throne one
throne
it says there out of thee bethlehem
shall he come forth unto me that is to
be ruler
in israel who's israel
us god's people he will be king
in us the kingdom of god is within
us and then it says even him whose
goings forth whose springs have been
from
old from everlasting you know christ
it talks about that revelation come unto
me all you that labor and are heavy
laden
and i will give you rest and in
revelation he says come unto me you
all you that are thirsty and i will give
you the water of life
the words i'm speaking unto you are
spirit and light
jesus is the fountain from which comes
the life of god and jesus is also
the word of god when we receive
god's word we are receiving the spirit
of god and the power of god
into our own lives yeah you know i
i can't help but wonder as i listen
to some of the things that you're saying
that there's a
i guess a modern um
movement or interpretation in
christianity that's a very kingdom now
um interpretation and it's very
physical manifestation you know very
earthly
like yeah god's gonna god's gonna come
down and set up his kingdom here on
earth and
and he is at some point
but it doesn't do god a whole lot of
good
to come and set his kingdom up on earth
if his subjects
aren't subject unto him
right so good point first he has to have
citizens
before he can have amen you know an
earthly kingdom here that is a very good
point
so not being the most important part you
know
our conversion is necessary first
otherwise
the internal kingdom the internal has to
happen before the external i mean yes
there's a kingdom in the sense that god
is still ruler of everything and all
that but
he wouldn't have you know subjects to be
a part of his kingdom
if we weren't um that's right
so micah and i'm glad you brought that
out because that's that
we're going to show something here in a
minute that ties the end with what he
just said
the inside has to be won before the
outside can be
fixed christ has to have his throne
listen to what it says in numbers
chapter 23
verse 19 it says god is not a man that
he should lie
neither the son of a man that he should
repent or change his mind
for hath he said and shall he not do it
or have he spoken and
shall he not make it good that one
promise
that's the whole gospel god said i'll
save you
do you believe him and i've
i've had people call me and i've been
there myself where
my sins were so overwhelming that i
thought
the enemy was whispering to me telling
me you've gone too far you've done this
too many times god cannot say
you've you've grieved the holy spirit
away it's lies
it's lies i read a statement
from a sister in christ and she said
something that really encouraged me she
said
we can do nothing more to dishonor god
than by doubting that he will save us do
you know why
because he said he would right and he
can't lie
now if you go over one more chapter in
uh
numbers chapter 24 this was where the
children of israel were
about to go into the land of canaan and
right on the verge of going into canaan
this one king
balak i think is how you pronounce his
name he was a pagan
and he was really nervous about a
million and a half israelites come
that would be if we had a million and a
half people crossing our border from
canada we'd be like
this is a problem or from mexico i mean
you'd be like a million and a half is a
lot of people
yeah balak said i got to do something
about this and he heard that there was a
quote
prophet a seer somebody that had
supernatural power so he called for
balaam and he offered him a lot of money
now this man was god's prophet but the
money was a lot of money
and balak told him said i'll give you
all this wealth i just need you to come
and curse these israelites
so that they can't prosper so they they
will not be able to overcome
and balaam got there and every time he
opened his mouth to curse
god would give a word and he would speak
through balaam and bless them
see every time he was supposed to curse
them they got stronger because he was
blessing them
and finally finally balak got so mad he
said just shut up don't say anything
else because every time you open your
mouth they're getting you know stronger
but listen to what balaam said during
one of these prophecies it says balaam
lifted up his eyes
and he saw israel abiding in their tents
according to their tribes
and the spirit of god came upon him and
he said
israel's king shall be higher than agag
and his kingdom shall be exalted
for there shall come a star out of jacob
and a scepter shall rise out of israel
do you know it's funny because it calls
christ this king a star
well didn't wasn't lucifer like a
falling star i beheld lucifer as a star
fall as lightning from heaven no in
malachi chapter four it talks about
christ and he's called the son of
righteousness
our son is the only star you can see
during the daytime
normally and then it says for out of
jacob shall come he that shall have
dominion and shall destroy him that
remains of the city
and israel which is who he lives in
shall do valiantly when i read that i
was like
he shall have dominion all right wait a
minute you know romans chapter 6 says
that sin does not have dominion over us
if christ comes in and takes the throne
sin
loses dominion it means it cannot
control you anymore
praise god so
we're talking about a king reigning
and there's another name for jesus
that's used all throughout
the scripture he's called the word
of god jesus says in john chapter
15 verse 1 through 7 he said if you
abide in me
and i am the word of god and if my words
which are spirit and life abide in you
you shall ask what you will and you'll
bear much fruit
without me you can do nothing hallelujah
and we can't bear fruit without him
except we abide in the vine
[Music]
jesus is the word of god so it's us
abiding in god's word
and god's word living and dwelling
and reigning within us that makes us
more than conquerors
this is a literal kingdom
now i want to show you um it's neat
because these old testament prophets
talked about this
messiah this king that was going to come
listen to what it says in the first book
of the bible
genesis chapter 49. this is when
jacob was blessing the 12 tribes his 12
sons
listen to what he says here this is
genesis 49 verse 8-11
it says judah thou art he
whom thy brethren shall praise for
thy hand shall be upon the neck of thine
enemies
now judah is where jesus came from he's
the lion of the tribe of judah
this prophesies that the messiah the
king
his hand will be on the neck of his
enemies hallelujah
praise god do you know we have got to
live that way
we are not we have not been given a
little 12-inch piece of ground and god
said okay i saved you
now just stand there and don't let
anything knock you off that little one
me
one 12-inch piece of ground god said
all the world is yours i took the
dominion back
go take the world go set the captives
free
amen amen you know what jesus said the
gates of hell will not
prevail against us i mean gates don't
attack people
people attack gates so when you see
somebody in bondage it's our job
to go after them to storm the gates
in prayer that doesn't i'm not talking
about physically
judah is also the first one listed in
revelation chapter 7
of the tribes when they're when it's
talking about 144 000.
oh really that's the first one yeah it
says here it's in
revelation uh chapter seven i'll start
in verse four and i heard the number of
those who were sealed
144 000 of all the tribes of the
children of israel were sealed
starts in verse 5 of the tribe of judah
12 000 were sealed oh wow
then is ruben then his gad asher
naphtali manasseh
and so on and there's one tribe missing
and
if you the man is missing yeah dan is
missing
i don't know if i've even brought this
out on the show but um
if you take all the meanings of their
names and you string them together in
order
it actually makes a little paragraph
so it's really kind of a interesting
thing okay well maybe
maybe next time we get together bring
that because i've seen other places
where it would go through a lineage and
when you looked at the original
names what they meant it was like yeah
it's really neat that would i would like
to
yeah so he says here
that judah and the king that will come
out of him his hand will be upon the
neck of his enemies
and then he says thy father's children
shall bow down before thee do you know
what's amazing
what were the angels called
that fell before they fell jared
sons of god isn't it funny
that hear the son of god
he says your father's children are going
to bow before you
do you know i think peter says at the
name of jesus i think it's peter it's
either peter or paul it says that the
name of jesus
every knee shall bow and every tongue
shall confess
do you know what's amazing if christ is
in us
everything that is his he's given to us
if we are his bride and we have become
one with him
every promise that was made to him is
ours
that means we don't have to fear we
don't have to
we're not living here like a weak
helpless
impotent christians and oh the devil's
the god of this world he's not he was
before calvary
but after calvary he's cast down
[Music]
then it goes on it says for the scepter
that's you know the ruling
rod that a king would hold the scepter
shall not depart from judah
nor a lawgiver from between his feet
until shiloh come the word shiloh in
hebrew means the peace giver
do you know ephesians says that he is
our peace
and remember melchizedek
christ is the high priest after the
order of melchizedek
meaning peace amen being interpreted
king of peace
and king of righteousness wow
that i get excited about this now this
is neat when i saw this i was like so
excited listen to this
until shiloh come and it says and unto
him shall the gathering of the people be
do you remember when jesus raised
lazarus from the dead
you can go back and read it in the
gospel i think it's in the gospel of
john
and it talks about that after he raised
lazarus from the dead the people
swarmed they were just thousands of them
around jesus
and do you know what the pharisees said
do you not see what's happening
the whole world has gone after him
exactly what that says that's the text
that i was going to bring up
what tell me the one you just said
that's in uh it's in john chapter 12.
but i was i was bringing i was going to
wait until the end
oh i'm sorry no it's all right no i've
done it no tell me well the only reason
i was
the only reason i was going to bring it
up is i'm thinking
down the road to part two because i just
read this
this morning and when i read it i was
like that kind of like clicked something
in my head
um so therefore the people who are with
him this is in
john 12 17. when he called lazarus out
of his tomb and raised him from the dead
bore witness for this reason the people
also met him because they heard that he
had done this the pharisees therefore
said among themselves
you see that you are accomplishing
nothing look the world has gone after
him
and i read that text and i was like this
is amazing because if you look at
um revelation chapter 13 it says the
whole world wanders after the beast
it's just another way that satan is
counterfeiting i didn't even think of
that you know
the work of christ now it says
wondered and this says um
the whole world has gone after him but
so and a lot of people will misread
revelation 13 and say the whole world
wandered after the beast it's not what
it says this is wondered you know
it's like they're in awe in amazement
they're they're taken in
by this power and
it's kind of the same thing here you
know it's like the whole world has gone
after and
they're amazed by jesus and and um so
anyway i think it's a
fascinating that you know that they said
that
and then it says something that is
really striking it says
binding his fall unto the vine
christ said i am the vine and you are
the branches
it says binding his foe that means the
the cult of a donkey under the vine
in his donkey's cult unto the choice
vine
he shall wash his garments in wine that
means
the juice of grapes unfermented
and his clothes in the blood of grapes
this was all the way back in genesis
speaking about what would happen when
the messiah came
now listen to what happened when he came
and this is taken from matthew 21
mark chapter 11 and john chapter 12. i
want to make sure i didn't like
miss something can you go back oh yes
yes break it down is it talking about
his garments being washed in blood is it
symbolic or something like
well it's like when he comes back it
says he's riding on a white horse and it
says he has
on a vesture as if it's been dipped in
blood
yeah it's because of what he went
through for us he says drink of this
juice it's my blood yes yes yeah i just
want to make sure i was
getting what was being said you know
it's funny because like in isaiah
chapter 1
it says though your sins be a scarlet
they shall be as white as snow
though they be red like crimson they
shall be as wool
how does god make my red stains
white by washing it in blood
that does not even make sense
but it's amazing because even even today
you ask
any woman what's the hardest thing to
get rid of it's red yeah
yeah that's in revelation 7 as well and
i said to him sir you know and he said
to me these are the ones who have come
out of the great tribulation
and washed their robes and made them
white in the blood of the land
oh wow that's revelation 7
wow 144 000. it's same chapter yeah
yeah 144 000. so
when it says he washed his garments and
wine and his clothes in the blood of
grapes
isaiah 53 says he took our personal
sins they were laid on him
jesus did not simply say god's got a
law whoever sins dies i'll pay the
penalty he didn't just
simply pay the penalty god put
our personal iniquities and
transgressions and sins on him
and do you know that he felt the guilt
of what we've done every single time
we've ever sinned
he felt the guilt as if he had done it
intellectually
he knew i didn't do that but his heart
said
you did he was i cannot imagine what
that was and he felt that for the entire
human race
well i mean yeah imagine if you you
stood up and said okay i'll take this
penalty for the speeding ticket
that's a lot different than saying i'll
take his penalty for the rape and the
murder charge
and feel the guilt as if i did it yeah
imagine now
everybody's sin of everything being on
one person man that's just
that's gotta kill you yeah i mean it's
what
it was so intense the bible said this
that he
sweat great drops of blood amen
that in that intensity and and i didn't
i didn't make this connection until
recently
but in the book of i think it's james
it's either james or hebrews it says i
think it's james
that um you have not yet resisted
unto blood that's right i'm thanking you
like jesus
resisted sin unto blood amen
the anguish that he went through the the
the heartache the
the resistance and it's like
we haven't gone that far that's a good
point
you know i i remember seeing a a
scientific
experiment one time that talked about
that sweating blood
and his natural water yeah like like
it's actually
um i mean this crazy incredible
painful experience but the fact that
your body could do that and
produce water and blood out your pores
is like
intense you know i'm glad that keith
brought that up though because you know
there's a verse in romans chapter 6
verse 10 and 11.
it says in that he died he
died unto sin once
him dying was not simply paying the
penalty
he had eric's adultery he had eric's
blasphemy he had eric's
alcoholism he had eric's cursing and
swearing
eric's watching bad movies
he had those and he looked at himself
and he was like
he had the feeling of what it felt like
when i wanted to do it
and he said by faith in my father's word
i choose to die rather than yield to
eric wilson's sin
and then it says in the next verse
romans 6 11 it says
reckon ye also yourselves to be dead
indeed unto sin but alive unto god amen
i think i know why i mix those up
because in james it says therefore
submit to god
resist the devil and he will flee from
you where's the other one
so the other one is in hebrews it's in
hebrews chapter 12 verse 4.
it says you have not yet resisted to
bless you striving against sin
okay so in one place it's telling us you
know uh
resist the devil and he will flee from
you
right well jesus resisted the devil
how did he resist the devil he didn't
want the word of god
yeah with the word amen right and
and even in the garden of gethsemane
when he is sweating those
great drops of blood he is having to
rely on the word of god to make it
through that experience because if he
doesn't
rely on the word of god he's not going
to make it through and that's why when
he was on the cross i mean he uttered
words that he himself had read
from psalms you know like my god my god
why have you forsaken me
um you know he's he's he's standing on
the word of god
amen knowing even though my body doesn't
you know like like my mind is fighting
against me but
i know this is real and he's quoting
scripture all the way to the end i mean
and you know that's what every one of us
are going to have to do right now living
in the days that we're living in
when you fall jesus says get up
he does not say stay down there i want
to leave you alone for six months i'm
putting you on probation
he says get up i have paid the price
if you will believe no matter what the
enemy is telling you in your head and in
your heart
you've got to say i know in whom i have
believed
the blood of jesus christ his son
cleanses me from all sin
i think there's a difference between
somebody who is stumbling and falling
and literally you know holding on to the
coat of
of jesus saying you know like i'm not
going to let you go and tell you
until you fix this right and and you see
in our world today
i mean there are people that are just
full-on whatever i'm a sinner and i'm
gonna
embrace that and i'm gonna just like go
for it i think that that even though
both are stumbling and falling it's like
the motive of the person that's like
well
you know i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
one person
yeah one person's happy and content to
be where they're at the other person is
like i've fallen but i want
out of here i want freedom yeah yeah
let me go on here um we're going to look
at where this was fulfilled when jesus
came
and we talked about this in matthew 21
mark 11 and john 12 it says
and a very great multitude spread their
garments
in the way in the path or the road and
others cut down branches from the palm
trees and strawed them
in the way or the road can you imagine
back then
clothing was expensive you go down and
you buy the most expensive
wedding gown for your wife you know it's
your first getting married and
it is a thousand dollars and somebody's
coming by and you go oh it's a muddy
road and you throw that thousand dollar
garment down
on the road for them to walk on that's
what the people were doing they were
saying
our righteousness is nothing filled me
right now this is
right before he goes to calvary right
yes i mean
yes does does the bible even say that is
it days is it that
week well this was the last yeah this
was the last visit
yeah okay i mean isn't that isn't that
amazing that we can turn
so fast yeah i mean that that that's an
alarming thought just
knowing like human nature there's
there's darkness
in there that can flip real fast when we
get to the second
part of this series it's going to show
why that happened
i'm always reminded of the israelites
same way yeah waters are parted you're
walking on dry land the enemy gets
destroyed and
moses disappears for a couple days and
they're worshiping
like a calf you know have you ever have
you ever found yourself doing
i found myself doing the exact same
thing god gave me an unbelievable
victory
a blessing and then all of a sudden i
find myself right back falling into the
same pit that i've fallen into before
whatever it is that's why it's a daily
coming back to god
and daily connecting and reconnecting
with him every single day
there's never a i got this you know and
it's like
the devil's just gonna wait for that
moment where you think you you're fine
and then he's going to trip you right
back up if if we do what jesus said and
we abide
we abide so that's what i'm i'm like
lord
you've grafted me and i'm holding on to
you
hold me yeah there's no pride in there
it's like what you're saying is it's
almost like he's waiting for us to get
to
that prideful moment where he is and
then he just
takes the rug right out from under yeah
[Music]
it says in the multitude that went
before jesus and those that followed
after
cried saying hosanna in the
hosanna to the son of david blessed is
he that cometh in the name
of the lord yahweh jehovah they called
him the son of david because
god had prophesied to david you're going
to have a son
and his throne will never cease his
kingdom will never
end
now this is where it gets interesting
so jesus is there preaching and you see
this all through the gospels
and he says why do you call me lord
lord and yet do not those things which i
say
do you remember when jesus came well i
don't want to get ahead do you remember
when he when the
wise men came and they were looking they
said where is he that is born
yeah king of the jews
jesus is there they're calling him son
of david you know they know who he is
he says why are you calling me lord the
word lord
in hebrew is adonai it means sovereign
king
in greek it interprets as master or king
ruler he said why do you call me your
king but yet you won't obey me
we could probably bring that a little
closer to home why are we called
christians yet
we don't act like it yeah talk about
taking god's name in vain that's it call
yourself a christian and live like the
devil
right can i go to that movie right that
pg
my wife was talking to me this past week
and she said a friend of ours had gotten
together
this was back 10 years ago and they said
we want to watch one of those old movies
we watched when we were younger and it
was like pretty in pink or something
she said they got through like 30
minutes of it and had to cut it off
because they were using
unbelievable bad language and
blaspheming god
as a pg so we call ourselves
christian but yet we're doing things
that christ
it would make him throw up so true
now fast forward to the story
jesus gets to the very end that entrance
into jerusalem
and they come and they take him the
pharisees do
and they get him in night which they
were not supposed to do you were not
supposed to have a trial at night time
that was against hebrew law
and god's law and they bring him to
pilate and pilate's roman
he's pagan but he has no
interest in putting jesus to death he
knows just by looking at him
this is a just man and then god
because christ wanted to save pilate so
bad
god sends a dream to his wife and his
wife comes out and she's like don't have
anything to do with this just man
i've suffered many things in a dream you
know because of him
and pilate you know is bringing jesus
there before the people
and he's asking you know what has he
done wrong
why are you wanting to kill him well
because he said you know he's a king
in luke chapter 19 verse 14 it actually
talks about what the people would say
and they said we will not have this man
reign over us
he came to be our king and they said we
don't want we don't want him
i got to bring this out before you move
on to there there's a really interesting
thing because you brought up how the
holy spirit was speaking to
pilate's wife right and um
actually all three of the godhead were
trying to reach pilate because
remember when it was asked of pilate um
you know
i or pilate says i have the power to
basically make that decision
and jesus says no the only power that
you have is what my father gives to you
right amen
so not only is jesus standing before him
but he's also saying
god has allowed you this position and
the holy spirit is
speaking to his wife yeah and it's like
all three of the godhead were
right there trying to win pilate and
pilate made those
wrong choices he condemned an innocent
man that he even himself said he was
innocent that's right and i think about
till you said it
that the holy spirit came to his wife
not him because imagine you know we
could have a dream and be like
whatever but if your wife tells you
something are you gonna go against what
she says are you gonna be sleeping on
the couch you know yeah yeah
he was like i better not you know like a
lot of times i've learned over the years
to listen to my wife yeah like sometimes
she'll come up with things and i'll and
you know first reaction be like what
that's so different but then it's like
you know they they do have a special
gift that i believe god has given to
them
that uh you know but also you know to
keep peace and stuff
in luke 23 verse 1 through 3 it says and
the whole multitude
of the jewish leaders arose and they led
him to pilate
and they began to accuse him saying we
found this fellow
perverting the nation and forbidding to
give
tribute or taxes to caesar saying
that he himself is christ a king
most christians don't realize what the
word christ means the word christ
actually means
the anointed so he claimed that he was
anointed
king herod was not anointed by god
he got in there through subtle you know
bribes and paying people off
so herod he wasn't even fully jew
so he wasn't supposed to be on the
throne
when he first found the wise men come
and they were asking the priest
where is this king that you know was to
come
herod was like what are they talking
about and the pharisees told him said
well all the way back in genesis
there was a prophecy that a king would
come that would rule
forever and herod was like i'm not ready
to step down off the throne
do you know i have found myself in that
position and i'll give you an example
with food god's like who are you going
to let
have the throne of your heart and
there's been times where i've allowed
christ to take that and there's other
times i'm like no no i got this i got
this
that part of my life is mine maybe it's
television maybe it's music maybe it's
books that you're reading
are you going to allow him are we going
to allow him to have the throne
and reign as king
this part is really intriguing
said then pilate entered in
to the judgment hall again and he called
jesus and said unto him
art thou the king of the jews
and if you look that word jews up it
actually is king of judah
it wasn't the king of the jews it was
the king of judah the one that
genesis 49 talked about so you
so you're saying that pilate was at
least
to some degree aware of the idea of a
messiah and he's claiming to be the
messiah or is he just saying the gr the
king over the actual jewish nation he
was saying the king over
that's who the pharisees were telling
pilate he claims to be king over judah
which means herod shouldn't be here
and they're doing that because if
there's an insurrection yeah
over who's supposed to be even herod
versus jesus
that that causes a whole world of mess
for pilate to have to clean up
and he doesn't want anything to he wants
things just to go smooth
because if there's insurrection then he
gets called back to rome and he's like
what's going on why are you not
keeping everything in in order so he
wants to keep peace
but he also doesn't want to condemn this
man that he knows
i mean you can look at like barabbas
they bring barabbas out and he's
spitting and cursing and fighting and
yelling and the two thieves that were
crucified with jesus
and jesus is not any of that and pilate
is a little i think he was he knew i'm
dealing with something here supernatural
i wonder if barabbas is going to be in
heaven i wonder if he changed his heart
man you know what i mean like he sees
jesus get crucified and he got let go
and that guy
got put on the cross instead of him i
don't know if it's like
down the road you know i think about you
know man
this guy took my my punishment you know
yeah
crazy so jesus
answered pilate and he said what thou
sayest
that i am a king and for this end was i
born and for this
cause came i into the world that i
should bear witness
to the truth and that hit me
he said i came to bear witness to the
truth what is truth
jesus well i know the truth in the life
pilate actually asked that question what
is truth
john chapter 17 verse 17 jesus answers
he says
sanctify them through thy truth thy word
is truth the word truth in greek means
unfailing verity god promised something
all the way back in genesis
5 thousand or four thousand years ago
and jesus is standing there saying
god promised it i'm the fulfillment of
that promise
i'm bearing witness to the truth of god
to the word of god
i am a king i am the truth i am the
fulfillment of the prophecy of the word
of god that's right
and he is the word in john 19 verse 1
through 4 it says then
pilate therefore took jesus and scourged
him you know with a whip
and the soldiers platted a crown of
thorns
and put it on his head and they put on
him a purple robe
and said hail king of the jews
and they smote him with their hands
pilate therefore went forth again and
saith unto the jewish leaders behold
i bring him forth to you so that you may
know that i find
no fault in him jesus said i came to
bear
witness to the truth you know that all
the way back in leviticus god had told
the jewish people i called my son out of
egypt
you're my son i called israel out of
egypt you're my firstborn he says in the
old testament
to israel that's speaking to us
you're my firstborn and then he told
them be holy because i'm holy
and people go well i'm trying he didn't
tell you to try
he said let there be light there was no
trying involved
with me let there be
light and there was there's power in the
word
amen and therefore it happens so going
interesting
it's fascinating that you know if you
look at this for for what it is
the um the state
had no problem that's right the state
recognized you know
he's innocent the church is the one that
found him at fault
that's that's a good point
[Music]
wow we're going to revisit that yeah i
know i'm just thinking about that
coming around to that but it's it's the
church
controlling the state that then that's
where he yeah that puts christ to death
in his saints i find it really
interesting and fascinating that here
you know pilate asks him what is truth
and then basically they put this crown
of thorns on him they beat him
and then right after that sentence he
says i find no fault in this man
like you beat him yeah because they they
prided themselves
on being the the judges of right and
wrong
and all of that and here he clearly is
acting
outside of that realm yeah even just
beating somebody that he didn't think
deserved it but he did it for the people
of the jewish nation so they would go
maybe you know ah
okay they beat him up okay we're good
now you know because if you look at paul
you know whenever he said i'm a roman
the romans got real nervous there yeah
that's right that's a good don't don't
touch that i forgot about that
that's right you know but jesus they're
like you know
the pressure was too great do you know
what's funny because
pilate said that three times i find no
fault in
three times he said that three times
that's important
jesus was showing the word of god cannot
fail god promised
a man can live without sin god promised
you know
all these promises jesus was like i'm
that promise i'm
showing you that god's word will do what
it says it'll do
he overcame by faith in god's word like
you said
we can overcome by faith god said
i cannot sin you know it says that in
first john chapter 3
it says he that is born of god does not
commit sin
for god's seed which is his word remains
in him
and he cannot sin for he's born of god
and people go
yeah but that that can't be true well
why well because i sinned last night
well god's not asking you about last
night he's asking you how can you sin
today knowing that god's word
is true do you know that first john
chapter 3
also says beloved we are the sons of
gods
it says that we the sons of god we were
begotten
with christ when he was resurrected from
the dead
so now he's just saying are you willing
to believe that are you willing to
believe that you are a son of god or a
daughter of god
i have a question yes sir what about if
because you were saying something about
pilate he had the control of that
and you know got the father
the son the holy spirit he was you know
talking to him you know like hey this is
my child don't do it or something like
that what about the prophecies
if he said you know what he's not going
to die
how the process the pro the prophecies
of the old testament
it's going to be like okay what if
pilate said you know what
jesus i'm gonna jesus is not gonna die
in crucifixion
do you think god had a different way to
how to pay our sins
the well the sins had to be paid for by
christ dying and this i've heard a
couple of people
talk about this terrible debt you know
i've heard a couple of people talk about
this
you remember when isaac when abraham was
told to take isaac upon the mountain
and offer him as a burnt offering isaac
laid down
he said father whatever the lord has
told you to do
he laid down when christ was going to
the cross
he laid down if something and this is
just my opinion okay
if something had happened if pilate had
had a conversion
what if the entire jewish nation had had
a conversion and accepted him you know
what jesus would have done i believe
i think he would have went into the
temple and he would have laid down on
the altar and he would have told the
high priest
i want you to kill me i'm laying my life
down for you all
can you imagine what that would have
done to the high priest to go how do i
kill somebody that i love
i i think also it's a demonstration of
the end conclusion of sin like
like i i always kind of say well you
know satan is a student of the bible he
knows what's going to go on how did he
let this play out in the way because he
understands the things of god the most
right so if he understands like he was
the closest to
god he understood what this mission was
that's how he's able to thwart it and
and and change and everything but i
think that this is the natural
end result of sin that you would condemn
an innocent man to die
all of us would probably do that if it
was playing out in a long enough
amount of time and so i think that this
he had to let
them take a man who did not deserve that
punishment and
bam do you know what's interesting and
keith you may remember
one of you guys may remember there's a
place in the new testament where paul
says
if they had known they would not have
crucified the lord of glory
herod pilate even satan
see but it's just crazy to me that that
that would be the case because
he watched the jews put the lamb on the
altar
so many years in a row and i
you know when he he was no doubt around
when john said behold here comes the son
of
uh of god that the lamb that takes away
the sins right i know it's interesting
though
spiritual things are only spiritually
discerned that's true satan did
not have the spirit of god so he could
see things but it was like
it was not as clear as what it is to us
that have the spirit of god in us
yeah the holy spirit was i mean he he
knows the bible you know from the
beginning at the end but
you know the inspiration is for through
the holy spirit if we don't have the
holy spirit i mean
it's just a dead life does that but no
inspiration
through the spirit that's why it's
important to pray when you read the
bible amen amen show me
show me what you want me to see lord
listen to this part this is what's
interesting the very next thing that
happened it says
then came jesus forth wearing the crown
of thorns and the purple robe
and pilate said something to him behold
the man do you know that's what the name
adam was he it means rudy
in flesh but it also means adam it was
the
first man pilate says behold
the man and i hear people and i know
they don't know any better but i hear
people on
television shows they'll say you're the
man
there's only one that's christ he is the
there's no human that can claim that but
it's funny because
in first corinthians 15 45 it says the
first
man adam was made a living soul but the
last adam
a quickening a life-giving spirit
christ is the second or the last adam
he took adam's place as the head of the
human race
adam was had dominion over the world
remember in genesis
he god gave him dominion of the entire
planet
every animal everything obeyed it even
the plants obeyed him
i wonder if he would have been like king
of the earth or something he would have
been prince
prince of this world his father's the
king he would have been the prince
that's why satan said i'm the prince of
the world but do you know what christ
came back and he said
i'm here to take back what adam lost
hallelujah
and this right here this is it this is
from a little paper a periodical that
was written back in 1898
it's called youth instructor july 7.
listen to what it says study the
scriptures
know that christ is to be set forth
among you
that means within you and that all that
was lost in adam
the cross of christ fully restores to
every believing soul
when you see the disciples after
pentecost they turned the world
upside down they healed the sick they
raised the dead they cast demons
they raised the dead they cast demons
out
peter would be walking along and to be
somebody that peter didn't even see
who looked and they were like that's
that's that man
he was a disciple of jesus and peter's
shadow would pass over them
and they would be healed without peter
even have anything to do with it
and it's not that peter had any power in
him
it was they were that connected with
their savior
and that's promised to us too right amen
amen
no i mean you know the poor out of the
spirit that's right
these miracles you will do and even more
and all the miracles really do is they
act as a catalyst for people to receive
the message
amen that's really the message that's
important that they work
that's right and that we're to be
preaching you know because we know
in the end of time satan will also use
miracles that's right
uplift or support bolster his work and
say
see i i there's miracles therefore it
must be true
but that's really the difference between
god's work and satan's word amen
is you know god's work is true
regardless
his message is regardless and it doesn't
need a miracle
to bolster it so if you use a miracle as
a barometer
you know you can be led astray by a
miracle yeah the miracle is just
let us stray by the truth the miracle is
not to be the test of whether
it's truth or error well look at the
pharisees
i mean they saw lazarus being raised
they saw all of these miracles
play out and i mean they called him you
know by the power of bl's above you're
doing this
so it wasn't necessarily the visual of
seeing this
you know amazing thing happen that
didn't convert their heart
so do you know what's funny and i'm glad
you brought this up keith
it's the message that matters do you
know what the message is
it says the gospel of the kingdom
the entire type that phrase in on a
search in the bible
how many times you see the word gospel
of the kingdom
it's over and over and over again
through the entire new testament the
word gospel means glad tidings
of the kingdom we saw what the word
kingdom means the sovereign reign of
christ
it's the glad tidings that christ reigns
when they went into the world and told
people
look why are you over there well i've
been a my whole life i've been a
prostitute
jesus forgave you he bore your sins in
his own body upon the tree
if you're willing to believe on him you
can stand up today and be
free and clean again no marks no sin
it's gone blotted out forever
that's what turns the world upside down
and you know if you go to revelation
um let me find this real quick it's
revelation chapter 14.
it actually talks about the three angels
messages yeah
revelation 14 verse 6 the first angel
and i saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven
having the everlasting gospel
the glad tidings to proclaim to them
that dwell on the earth
the gospel is what christ did listen to
what second corinthians 4
6 says for god who said let
light shine out of darkness has shone in
our hearts to give the light
of the knowledge of the glory of god in
the face of jesus christ
you see that word right there knowledge
it's knowing
that word actually means knowing he has
shown in our hearts to give us the light
the revealing of the knowing of the
glory of god
christ knew his father so much his face
glowed
god was in him and you remember where's
that that it says
this is life eternal that they might
know thee
certainly amen
so that's what god wants he wants us to
accept what christ has done on calvary
and that doesn't mean okay i'm going to
keep living in sin it's like what paul
says
how can we that are dead to sin continue
to live in that
but we've got to know that we died amen
amen
wow wow you know what this is exciting
and and the next the next part when we
go into the kingdom of darkness and i
hate to spoil it for the devil but we're
going to show the darkness but it's got
even more lights right yeah i like that
we focused on the light today that was
good
beautiful so we kind of started out
talking about or i was asking this
question about you know
um the voices in your head you know
and this is why just to kind of bring it
full circle this is why it's important
that
this is what we put in our head amen
yeah so this voice that we'll hear
you know jesus said this is the way to
walk you in it um
this is what needs to be in our minds
and so
when this comes to mind we know that
that is truth
and that we're safe in obeying that
other things
not so sure about that's right so like
we said in the beginning if you want to
if you want to know if you're getting uh
the right messages you have to get them
from the right source so you know i'm
glad keith brought that up too because
if this this is called the bread of life
if this is what i'm eating i mean like
if every day if i'm not doing this as a
ritual but i'm doing this because i want
to know what the promises are
if we hide his word in our heart when an
emergency
comes that's what will come back to the
mind
those promises talk about the blood uh
i know we were talking about the blood
and everything i just found very
amazing in the revelation chapter 12
verse 11
and they say and they overcame him
by the blood of the lamb and by the word
of the testimony
and they did not love their lives to the
dead
amen i mean that's that's really amen
i mean i cannot wait you know i mean
amen
and what that verse i think really kind
of means to me is that they were so in
love with the truth
that they would rather die than defile
their god or go against what god had
said and that testimony
was literally like what jesus i would
rather die
than to to sin against god you know
and you know it's cool because we've
already been given that promise let this
mind
be in us which was in christ he was
willing to die rather than sin and his
mind is ending
and in you and in you that's the thing
do we believe it
and that's what faith comes by hearing
and hearing by the word
everything that god does points us back
to the word so the more that you read it
and i encourage all of our
our brothers and sisters that are
listening and watching
read god's word out loud when you're
reading devotions
read it out loud and read your name into
the promises
when you do that i used to struggle
because i used to always want to um
memorize bible verses i couldn't
memorize them i just was no good at it
and when i started reading the bible out
loud i never even had to try
it's like all of a sudden while you're
reading it out loud god's spirit is
writing it on every fiber of your being
and i i remember you telling me one time
um to
to just add a couple of words to each
one of the ten commandments
as as as if it was a promise i
will have no other gods before me amen i
will not have a graven image i will
you know uh not take the lord's name in
vain and that's right
it really kind of changes the context of
that but really you can read the ten
commandments as a promise that god is
saying
that my spirit will be in you like what
ezekiel 36 says
yes you will keep my judgments and my
statutes that's a promise
that is a promise and it's by those
promises that we are made partakers
of his divine nature hallelujah
praise the lord that's great okay so
we're going to keep this going for two
more hours right
this is good i love it awesome well it's
a good time to plug
the bible studies right yeah yeah
so if you are um out there in our
listening audience and you want to
uh you know dig into the word of god
more we have
a series of videos that we had developed
a couple years ago called video bible
studies
we are ramping up on those again and so
as you're
watching you should see notifications
about that in the near future
we have short little videos or five
minutes or less
also written bible studies that go along
with them to
help you get deeper into the word of god
and even beyond that we have our own
bible school
so we'll put the link to that bible
school and the description below in this
video
and if you want to learn more about the
bible the life of jesus even if you're a
young person we have
studies designed specifically for that
so we invite you to
look those up and become more engaged in
the word of god
so i hope this message has been a
blessing for you and we will see you
next time this has been led live
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the dualist who they say can speak
with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern from
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got
the idea from a cartoon network show
mom it's mr sadie i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
visit our brothers at school for
prophets.tv and watch from babylon to
america which has over 5 million views
on youtube alone
and follow it up with america 2 babylon
check the description below for links to
this and more
[Music]
you